Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt Wir haben es verbunden. Unterhaltung und Wissen und wer genau das gemacht hat, das wisst ihr natürlich. Habt ihr schon in dieser kleinkirrigen Stimme gesehen, dass er ist Stefan Tietze, Stefan Tietze, Stefan Tietze, Hustet. Glückwunsch, es gibt wenig, was man beim Husten sagen kann. Gute Besserung macht man... Verschluck dich nicht. Hör auf zu husten, sagt man in der Regel. Lass es.
Lass es.
In hüftlicher Umbegebung sagt man, hör auf bitte. Und Florentin Will. Ja, danke. Nee, du hast tatsächlich sehr viel ge... Erzähl jetzt mal, wer das Intro gemacht hat. Das Intro kommt dieses Mal von Max. Max. Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Running Gag mittlerweile ist, weil ich glaube, die letzten acht Intros waren alle von Max. Ah, okay. Oder es ist Klaus Badet, der sich mit falschem Namen doch noch gemeldet hat. Wir wissen es nicht, vielleicht eines Tages. Du hast jedenfalls neulich, wir waren zusammen eine Show, ich sage nicht wo, eine Show geguckt und oder Kino und du hast die ganze Zeit gewusstet. Ah, das war das Schlimmste. Ich hasse ja zu stören. Ich wusste es, dass ihn das so beschäftigt und er das so hasst. Weil wir alle kennen Florentin, wir alle kennen seine Potensionen, seine Kampagnen gegen Störer, gegen Störerinnen, Störer. Du hast die GO ins Leben gerufen, die Gesellschaftsordner, die eingreifen. Sowas wie die SS. Richtig. Ich sag nicht, es ist sowas wie die SS im gesellschaftlichen... Ich sag nicht welcher Aspekt, sondern es ist sowas wie die SS, es hat Anteile und deswegen wenn Florantina neben einem sitzt und hat einen Hustenanfall, während der Vorstellung, weiß ich, es stört die Leute nicht so sehr wie ihn selber. Es ist wirklich furchtbar vor allem, ich hab natürlich auch Wolfgang Schmidt im Ohr, liebe Grüße, der in seinem Podcast auch mal gesagt hat, er war irgendwie in einem Konzert und es hat ihn am meisten aufgeregt, dass die Leute gerustet haben und er meinte, kann man da nicht irgendwie Hustenbonbons verteilen oder so, kann man da nicht was dagegen machen, sagen, bitte mach das nicht und das sind genau die Gedanken, die ich mir auch mache. Ich möchte wie im Flugzeug dann so, wo dann so die Atemmasten runterkommen, dass so ein Ricola von der Decke kommt. Genau, ja.
Also es ist ein Richt so.
Geben Sie erst sich so ein Ricola von der Decke kommt. Genau, ja. Also es ist ein Richtiges.
Geben Sie erst sich selber ein Ricola und dann den Kindern.
Dann helfen Sie den anderen.
Und dann hängst du da so an der Schnur dran, hätte ich gut gefunden.
Und es ist ja so dumm, weil dein Körper checkt ja nichts,
der checkt ja keine Signale.
Aber es sind nur Köder.
Dann hast du dann die älteren Männer, die daran nuckeln,
weil sie Husten haben, dann haben die so was ausgelöst, dann haben die so einen Trikulamund und dann wird es hochgezogen wie so Fische. Und dann hängen die oben an der Decke. Die werden dann so aus dem Saal raus katapultiert und stören nicht mehr. Landen direkt im Rhein. Das ist bei der Philharmonie in Köln ganz praktisch, weil man die einfach in den Rhein katapultieren kann. Ja, es ist grossartig. Toll, das ist absolut wundervoll. Das neunte Weltwunder sagt man ja, aber die können wir hier. Und ja, es ist absolut furchtbar. Und ich hatte dann zum Glück irgendwann Süssigkeiten und Bonbons und weiss auch nicht, ob das auch unhöflich ist, aber habe versucht, die zu lutschen und meinen Rachen zu bewässern. Ob das klappt oder nicht, weiss ich nicht. Ketzerische Frage. Helfen Hustenbonbons? Ich glaube schon ein bisschen. Also allein dieses konstante Speicheln und so ist schon eine gute Sache. Das ist das irgendwie beruhigt oder so. Aber ist nicht Husten, ich habe was in der Lunge, also der ganze Luftröhrenaspekt ist der belastete und das andere hat auch nichts damit zu tun, dass Menricola kommt doch niemals mehr Luftröhren. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass dadurch, dass mehr Speichel produziert wird und so und dann da irgendwie so singt, dass du dann mehr Schleim abhusten kannst. Weil ich glaube, das Problem ist, wenn du zu oft trocken hustest, dann kriegst du es nicht raus, sondern du willst hier durch Husten irgendwas rauskriegen oder irgendwie woanders hin. Eben. Und je mehr Speichel und Verschleimung und so, desto glaube ich, ist es einfach wie so ein Lösungsmittel und dass es dann mitschlonzt oder was. Keine Ahnung, die HNO-Fraktion kann uns da gerne korrigieren. Oder ist da ein Mittel drin und dass durch das Atem der Minze oder whatever, durch das Einatmen wird deine Luftröhre beruhigt oder sowas. Es ist wirklich furchtbar und ich habe das jetzt schon seit ein paar Tagen und jetzt war ich letztens beim Zahnarzt und da denkt man ja immer so, mit dem Zahnarzt, wenn da der Hustenreiz kommt, dann hast du einfach verloren. Dann bist du einfach schachmatt. Nicht schlucken, nicht schlucken, rede ich mir ein, Stefan, nicht schlucken, nicht schlucken, nicht schlucken. Beim Zahnarzt, ich will nicht schlucken, denke ich mir, ich will nie so gerne schlucken, nicht falsch verstehen, lustig, lustig, lustig, man kann es falsch verstehen. Aber ich will nie so gerne schlucken wie beim Zahnarzt.
Comedy-Rakete, Stefan Tietzer, will ich Abwehrhaltung geben.
Ja, Leute, also das wäre zu einfach.
Comedy-Schild. Stop, stop, Stop, Comedy-Schild.
Nein.
Wortspiel-Schild.
Das ist Podcast-Ufo-Wortspiel-Schild.
Stefan ist heute auch zu spät gekommen.
Stop, das Podcast-Ufo-Comedy-Schild. Der Podcast-Ufo-Comedy-Schild. Der Podcast-Ufo-Comedy-Schild.
Das Podcast-Ufo-Comedy-Schild, Antivirus. Hier wird nicht gespast. Hier ist aufhören mit diesen einfachen Gags.
Oh, Stefan will nie wo lieber schlucken als beim Zahnarzt. Nee, nein, nein, nein. Stopp, hier nicht weiter.
Man könnte es verstehen als sexuelle Anspielung. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Wissen, wo Schluss ist. Wissen, das ist, genau, das ist zu einfach. Wissen, dass Schluss ist. Und dann alles so ein Schwarz-Weiss-Film beginnt dann, wie dann diese Witze gemacht wird und so. Und das ist Stefan Dietze. Er hat in seiner Vergangenheit auf der Einbahn weniger schlechte Witze gemacht. Ich meinte nicht diese Art Schwarz-Weiss-Film. Ach so, Entschuldigung. tra, ah, das wurde schon wieder der gleiche Witz gemacht und dann ist eine Klaviermusik hinterlegt, wie so ein trauriges Schicksal.
Und dann sitzt und dann zoomt man so raus und du sitzt in so einem Kinosaal und alle sagen so, wir haben alle auch diesen Witz schon gemacht und du zoomst immer weiter raus und es sind wahnsinnig viele. Das ist der grösste fucking Kinosaal. Und dann so eine Atombombe, die dann so auf, also man muss halt angucken, dass man das richtige Bild findet. Oder halt irgendwie so ein Hubschrauber, der so reinfliegt. Der so reinfliegt, ja. Was? Ja, dass man sagt, mach das nicht. Alle, die sind in dem... Hast du Mordfantasien gegenüber Leuten, die die Störenden im Ruhrabteil? Oh ja, oh ja, auf jeden Fall. Das auch und die früh irgendwie Lärm machen. Ich habe oft das Problem, dass ich meinen Tag versuche gut zu kontrollieren und mir denke, an dem Tag wäre es eigentlich geil, lang auszuschlafen. Und dann versuche ich, möglichst am Vortag lange wach zu bleiben. Und dann hast du immer das Risiko, dass irgend so ein Straßenreinigungstyp Renegade einfach sagt, ach, es ist sechs Uhr dreißig, ich bin wach,
die Strassen können doch jetzt gereinigt werden.
Und dann schwingt er sich auf sein Apparell und dann geht's los.
Und hat auch diese Bassdrum auf dem Rücken
und dieses, wo man
diese Alleinunterhalter, die durch die Strassen laufen,
diese ganzen Seile.
Presslufthammer an der Seite.
Und dann wirst du geweckt von so einem
Dauert es um fünf Minuten?
Jetzt kommen wir zurück.
Warum fährt das denn? Wie dünn muss ein Gerät sein, dass es locker achtmal die fucking Strasse entlang ist. Ich stelle mir so ein Skateboard-breites Strassenreinigungsgerät vor, das immer so leicht versetzt nochmal an der Strasse vorbeifahren muss. Ach so. Das kam so oft vorbeigefahren, das ist einfach lächerlich. Das kann gar nicht so dünn sein. Es könnte gar nicht fahren, wenn es so dünn wäre. Wie so dünn. Weil es dann ja ganz oft hin und her muss. Zu schwach. Du kennst es ja vom, nein, du kennst es noch vom Rasenmäher. Wenn du den Rasenmäher fährst. Du machst doch nicht die Mitte, wohnt zu der Fußgängerzone oder was. Nee. Dann verstehe ich es. Ja, aber du fährst doch nicht in der Mitte lang. Ist ja nicht wie so eine Eispräpariermaschine bei Eishockey-Spielen oder Eisrings, sondern es ist ja, du fährst einmal am Bordstein lang an den anderen Bordstein zurück. Genau. Und was sind die anderen sechs Fahrten?
Es ist zu schwach. Ich meine, es ist nicht zu dünn. Es kann sogar noch dünner sein. Das würde das Problem nicht verhindern. Es müsste genauso auffahren als zu schwach. Ich habe es mir in meinem übermüdeten 6.30 Uhr Gehirn vorgestellt, dass so ein Skateboard-breites Gerät einfach so wie so ein Rasenmäher, der dann so einen Streifen sauber macht. So ein ganz dünner, schlanker Mann ist da drin. Der wirklich wie auf so einem Rennrad so ganz nach vorne gestreckt draufliegt und dann einfach wo du denkst dir, gibt es noch eine ineffizientere Art, diese Aufgabe zu erfüllen. Absolut furchtbar, aber wenn sich... Ganz grosser Unsinn, also ich glaube, es ist einfach zu schwach. Ich meine, wir müssen uns mal anders ansetzen bei dem Problemansatz. Wenn es zu schwach ist, dann lass es in der Garage. Nee, ich meine, aber warum, es fällt ja nur an den Bordstein lang. Es müsste nur zweimal. Der Fakt, dass du es mehr als zweimal gehört hast, heißt, entweder fuhren mehrere Geräte bei dir vorbei, weil der noch, weil der wach gemacht werden muss. Flur, der will heute Morgen, der kann heute ausschlafen, wir schicken mal die ganze Brigade vorbei. Oder aber es ist zu schwach und es saugt nicht richtig. Oder dieses Kreisding, fantastisch, wirdirgendwo anders genutzt die vorstellung dass du so ein 18 tonnen schweres teil hast und fährst durch die strasse und hinten ist es nahezu identisch und all die ganzen kaugummi Papierchen und Blätter bleiben einfach liegen wie so ein Staubsauger und dann fährst du drüber und es nimmt nichts mit weil du kennstst doch diesen Trimmer, du trimmst ja auch deinen Bart. Der ist ja, und ich weiß nicht, was du für einen Trimmer hast, aber wenn du einmal drüber gehst, ist nahezu nichts. Nichts, ja, unverändert. Eben, das meine ich. Der schläft aber die ersten drei Mal auch, der sagt, ach komm, die ersten drei Mal mein nix. Ich verstehe es nicht, weil ich gehe einmal dr ja, es ist nichts passiert. Und man verändert nichts und dann erwischt er mal noch ein Haar und mal noch ein Haar und ich denke mir, nee, ich will eigentlich ein Gerät haben, was alles wegschneidet. Ich verstehe gar nicht, wieso schneidet er das nicht weg? Ja, der überschätzt sich jedes Mal. Der denkt immer beim ersten Mal, kein Problem, Bata, mal locker hier neben Bayern, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,atterbandaufgang vor meine Haustür, wo drauf stand, nicht betreten bis 15 Uhr. Stell dir mal vor, du weißt, wann wir sonst noch nehmen. Wollte uns eigentlich irgendjemand heute von der Aufnahme abhalten? Ich glaube auch. Ich werde früh morgens geweckt, du wirst in deiner Wohnung gehalten. Ist das die verfluchte Aufnahme, in der wir beide sterben, wo irgendwie hier was passiert? Nee, ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, wir haben es zu Hause, fliegen jetzt unsere Wohnung in die Luft. Ich glaube, hier sind wir gerade sicher, wir haben es ja geschafft. Ach so, das kann auch sein. Ja, das kann auch sein. Aber was ein komisches Problem, die Wohnung nicht verlassen zu können. Und ich wollte Sport machen, ich hatte wahnsinnigen Hunger und wollte mich raus, weil dann morgens haben die dann so eine Paste aufgetragen, wo ich drin stecken geblieben wäre, haben die so ein Ding aufgespannt. So eine Klebefalle für Mäuse, du einfach so komplett auf dem Bauch liegst und wächst klebst. Herr Tietze, wir haben doch extra ein Schild aufgegeben, klebst im ganzen Körper einfach da drin. Warum haben wir ihre Zunge? Ich weiss, es sieht lecker aus, aber wir haben nur extra ein Schild auf, klebst im ganzen Körper einfach da drin.
Warum haben wir Ihre Zunge? Ich weiß, es sieht lecker aus, aber wir haben doch extra ein Schild aufgehangen. Haben Sie erst versucht, es abzulecken und dann kam der Rest des Körpers? Und dann hilft bei mir so und ich renne sofort weg wie so ein Tier. Oder du rennst direkt nochmal rein. Och, Herr Tietze. In so ein großes Licht, wie so eine Motte, die dann so recht rein. Ja, dann, also, und dann kam, habe ich ein Paket bekommen und er kam dann nicht zu mir. Und ich war da und er so, ja, und ich so, ja, und dann, ja. Das ist dann so, du musst mit dem Huhn rüber, dann gehe ich mit dem Fuchs rüber mit dem Paket. Der DHL-Bote und der FedEx-Mann dürfen nicht gleichzeitig auf dem Uf, auf dem Kanu sein.
Genau, ja, und das Kratzeis und Stefan dürfen nie gleich zusammen sein, sonst isst er das sofort auf.
Ja, probt dann und dann jetzt hat er es wieder mitgenommen. Und dann gab es das Moment, man sieht sich...
Moment, da kann man nicht werfen oder so?
Nein, nicht werfbar, keine Wurfbereitschaft.
Was bestellt man, dass nicht werfbar ist?
Nee, ist zu hoch, es war zu hoch, ich war im zweiten Stock. Es war nicht hochwerfbar. Ach, ging nicht. Ich glaube, ich könnte so ziemlich jede Lieferung bei dir in die Wohnung werfen. Sag ich jetzt hier, wir können eine Outdoor-Folge machen bei Stefan zu Hause, wie ich verschiedene Bestellungen in grösser werdender Komplexität und Grösse und Umfang und Leichtigkeit.
Ich glaube, leichte Dinge sind schwerer, so ein grosser, leichter Karton ist, glaube ich, sehr schwer hochzuwerfen.
Du hast mir das Podcast-Dufo zeigen, Schatz. Ja, genau, aber nicht diese Folge, weil die haben diese, wieso nicht diese Folge?
Also ich habe hier, also Leute, ich stehe jetzt hier direkt vor Stefans Wohnung und ich habe jetzt hier einen Paket direkt dabei und ich versuche sie vorzuwerfen, okay? Ne, diese Folge nicht hören, Schatz, diese Folge nicht hören, weil da werfen sie, was, wieso, was machen sie denn da, zeig mir das doch einfach. So, ich habe jetzt den kleinen Karton, da ist was hartes drin. Ne, da werfen sie immer grösser werdende Kartons in Stephans Wohnung. Aber warum machen sie das? Warum ist der Wind draußen so stark? Warum machen sie das? Das Parkett fliegt weg! Der Wind! Der Wind! Ja, irgendwie weiß ich nicht. Mir wurde das mal empfohlen vor ein paar Monaten, aber irgendwie hat sich die Welt verändert. Lass uns was anderes hören, lass uns doch einen True Crime Podcast hören. Immer diese Podcast beim ersten Date, nur weil es einmal in der Reader's Digest drin stand, machen das jetzt alle. The Reader's Digest, ist es nicht eher The Listener's Light Digest? Sehr gut. The Reader's Digest selgt am eigenen Ast, wenn sie Podcasts empfehlen. Das stimmt, ja. Es gibt viele Magazine, die Podcasts empfehlen, ich sag mir, Leute, Leute, wir spielen mit Feuer. Das ist so, als würde der Architectural Digest Obdachlosigkeit empfehlen. Ja, stimmt. Oder schöner Wohnen, keine Möbel. Ja, schöner Wohnen macht Werbung für Campingwagen. So, Leute, ihr seid euch sehr sicher, dass euer Konzept funktioniert. Minimalism. Minimalism. Minimalism. Oder als würde zum Beispiel Angler-MagMagazin sagen, aber kauft euch noch den Fisch im Supermarkt.
Ich mache jetzt einen Angelschein.
Das ist die nächste Phase, ich freue mich, was es wird.
Ich bin so gespannt, wir wissen es nicht.
Macht der Yoga oder Schlagzeug, Bingo oder Cash, geht er ins Casino oder holt er sich einen Schein zum Fliegen eines Segelflugzeuges? Steffans neue Phase ist da! Und du hast dich entschlossen, Tiere zu töten? Ja, Angelschein. Du hast dich also entschlossen, diesen armen Wesen etwas Köstliches vor die Nase zu halten und darin ein hartes Metallhaken, wiederhakenbewehrtes Gerät zu verstecken im Wurm, so dass der Fisch, zwischen dem es eigentlich mal einen Gesellschaftsvertrag gab, zwischen Fisch und Mensch, der jetzt nichts ahnend diesen Wurm beisst und denkt, der wird ins Wasser gefallen sein.
Hast du dich inzwischen verstanden, wie meine Phasen funktionieren? Du fragst mich jetzt, ob ich angeln will. Es kommt nicht zur Tötung. Nein. Will ich angeln? Nein. Will ich entscheiden? Hell yes. Ja, ja. Ich will meine Scheine haben. Ich habe dich nie als Fischmensch gesehen. Doch, ich mag Fisch, aber ich möchte vor allem Scheine haben. Ich möchte mehr Scheine haben. Ich fange jetzt damit an und ich habe schon meinen Bootsführerschein, meinen Gabelstaplerführerschein, Angelschein, Jagdschein, irgendwann gar kein Interesse eigentlich, Flugschein, definitiv irgendwann, Golfplatzreife, obviously Scheine, Scheine, Scheine. These, du bist einfach nur eitel und brauchst Gründe, um Fotos von dir selber zu machen.
Ähm, ja, Gegenthese, Scheine führen zur Lebensqualität. Okay. Fotos von mir machen. Naja, ich habe mir gerade vorgestellt, da ein Geldbeutel und wie du so kramst und du hast so wirklich reihenweise Scheine, wo immer dein Gesicht drauf ist. Und da dachte ich mir, oh, ist das nicht auch eine Art Spiegelkabinett? Einfach, dass du dich verewigst, dass dein Bild überall zu sehen ist, dass du dich überall auf der Karte haben willst und einen guten Grund brauchst, ein Fotoshooting zu machen. Weil ich habe deinen Reitschein gesehen und das war ein schöner, also ein geschmackvoller Akt da als Bild. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das gemeint war, als es hieß, bringen Sie ein Passfoto mit. Das war ein wundervoller, das war ein sehr, sehr geschmackvoller Akt. Genau, meine Partnerin und ich haben gemeinsam einen Reitschein gemacht und wir sind beide komplett nackt auf diesem grossen Schimmel. Stopp, Sexgag-Verbot! Auch wenn er sagt, er hat mit seiner Partnerin einen Reitschein gemacht, ist damit nichts Sexuelles gemeint. Nein, ach so, nee. Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, Rettungsschirm. Der Podcast-Ufo-Comedy-Rettungsschirm, den wir gerne auf andere Podcasts schützend legen wollen, damit die keine unlustigen Gags machen. Ja, glauben wir, was wir sind? Was für eitle Fatzken. Man muss sagen, das war ein schönes Fotoshooting. Und ich habe das Gefühl, du hast dich da auch echt gefunden in dieser Soft-Erotik. Ich glaube, du bist kein Hardcore-Typ. Nein, Soft-Erotik. Ich glaube, du bist eher so ein Softcore-Typ. Also so, ja, Halberektionen und auch, sage ich mal, so geschmackvolle Posen aus dem Alltag. Also jetzt nicht so, ich liege auf einem Lammfell mit gespreiztem Bein, sondern eher, du warst der Barista, wo du nur die Schürze anhast. Aber mein Glied zeichnet sich deutlich ab. Aber du bist in einer normalen Barista-Situation, es ist keine lastive Pose. Für die FSK, die ja immer entscheiden muss, sind Filme ab 16, ab 18, ab 6, ist der Peniswinkel entscheidend. 45 Grad ist bis 16, ab 45 Grad aufwärts ist ab 18. Okay.. Das heißt ... Aber von alleine. Wie? Also angenommen, es gäbe jetzt eine Szene, in der man ein nicht erregiertes Glied sozusagen in diese Position bringen würde. In welche Position? In die 90-Grad-Situation. Nee, wie gesagt, alles über 45 ... Es geht nicht um den Erektionszustand, es geht um den Winkel. Es geht um den Winkel. Ja, wenn man jetzt händisch ... Hoch hält. In der Comedy-Szene. Ja. Du machst den Helikopter. Du machst den Kaffee und dann sagst du, hoffentlich verschütte ich den Kaffee nicht, sonst tue ich mir weh. Die Kamera schwenkt runter und sieht, dein Glied liegt auf dem Tresen. Nicht irrigiert. Allerdings im 90-Grad-Winkel von dir ab. Er muss es alleine aus eigener Kraft heraus. Aus eigener Kraft muss der kleine Stefan es schaffen, die 45 Grad zu überwinden. Angenommen, man schafft das jetzt selbst im irrigierten Zustand nicht. Habe ich auch gedacht. Es gibt ja verschiedene Menschen mit verschiedenen Penissen. Nicht alle sind ja gleich irrigiert. Ich will sogar nicht behaupten, manche haben sehr früh einen 45 Grad Zustand erreicht, manche erreichen ihn vielleicht nie. Es hat ja auch was mit der Hodenunterstützung zu tun. Also oft heben ja die Hoden noch, es ist ja wie bei einem WG-Umzug. Du meinst Hängehoden oder Hubhoden? Jeder Mann hat entweder gute Freunde, die viel heben bei einem Umzug von der WG und hat gute Hoden, die einfach mitheben, die einfach eine gewisse Stütze geben. So. Halt, stopp! Dieser Sex-Gag geht zu weit. Okay, sorry, nehme ich zurück. Das Podcast- Rettungsschirm wurde aktiviert. Es ist wieder Iron Dome. Der Schmuddelknopf. Es ist wieder Iron Schmuddel-Dome. Wir haben so eine Comedy-Iron Dome. Wie auch über Israel, wo wenn da kleine Raketen kommen, wird alles irgendwie direkt alle Filz-Sex-Gags abgeschossen. Ja, finde ich gut. Vielleicht müssen wir auch freier werden. Vielleicht wollen das auch die Leute. Vielleicht sind wir auch deswegen so unerfolgreich, weil wir immer Sex-Gags aussparen. Vielleicht müssen wir die Hosen runterlassen. Wir hatten lange Zeit im Podcast die sehr erfolgreichen Stefan-Fick-Tipps, jetzt wird gefickt und das kam eigentlich ganz gut an, aber dir ging dann relativ schnell die Luft aus, also du die Themen. Das waren zwei erfolgreiche Folgen, aber danach, also als wir über das Format geredet haben, wir machen komische Geräusche, das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen, ich habe gerade gemerkt, wie ich so, obwohl ich nichts sage und nur zuhörig oder so mache.
Weißt du,
ich habe es auch schon bei meinem Onkel beobachtet.
Man kommt irgendwann in ein Alter, wo man... Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, genau. Ja, wo man auch seinen Körper, sein Körper ist nicht mehr gestimmt.
Man verrät mehr. Man vergisst,
dass man Geräusche macht. Und man verliert seinen Pokerface.
Man sagt wahnsinnig viel über seinen
...
Wenn man so, man macht sich bereit zu lachen oder so.
Man muss alles mit Anlauf nehmen.
Jesus Christ.
Ich gehe auch kaputt. Ich merke, ich häute mich.
Ich häute mich, meine Haut hat keinen Bock mehr.
Reptuli, Furentin Reptiloid,
confirmed. Kann gut sein und
ich finde den Moment geil, wo ja anscheinend
die Haut sagt, so, jetzt, jetzt, ich gehöre hier nicht mehr hin. Zwei Wochen Tunesien, ich bin raus. Leute, wir haben hier echt eine geile Zeit gehabt, die Epidermis und ich, aber ich fühle mich einfach nicht mehr als Teil meines Körpers. Und da sage ich auch, Haut geht dein Weg. Wohin geht die dann Haut? Ich weiß es nicht, es ist aber vor allem, also angenommen man, vielleicht sprechen von sich anders aus. Angenommen man häutet sich, wird dann die zweite Schicht zur ersten Schicht und unten geht was nach. Ja, und dann wächst die obere nach. Und dann sagt die zweite Schicht, so jetzt bin ich dran. Weil die zweite Besetzung beim Theater, wo wenn die erste Besetzung krank ist, dann kommt die zweite Besetzung und so bei der Haut, wenn die die erste raus ist, kommt die zweite und sagt so, dafür haben wir geprobt, Schweiss, ich weiss alles, Haare, Gänsehaut, krieg ich hin, let's go. Und man hat dann erstmal Gnade, es ist nur die Ersatzbesetzung. Man hat mir eine Gnade. Ich verstehe es nicht, also bei Heizähnen hast du wirklich das Besetzungsding. Du hast Reihenzähne und wenn einer ausfällt vorne, wird von hinten die Reihen nachgeschoben. So wie der Nationaltorwart, wo es immer drei gibt und alle wissen, der dritte, der fährt nach Hause und hat die Schuhe nicht ausgepackt. Das ist immer kontraktiv, weil ich immer denke, warum wächst nicht einfach von unten einer nach? Wie bei allen anderen Haare zum Beispiel. Haie, warum braucht ihr diese Extrawurst?
Okay, ihr seid eine alte Spezies. Chill the fuck out.
Weiss der Hai, wie viel Zähne er noch hat? Also sagt der Hai, oh scheiße, ich verliere meinen Zahn.
Nein, nein, der Zahn, dann fliegt er so den Wasser runter in die Dunkelheit.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, kommt von hinten, ich bin wie das bei Jurassic Park, dieses kleine, mit so einem kleinen Schnorchel aber auch, dieses kleine Mr. DNA.
Ja, hallo, du bist ein kleiner Hai, lass mich erklären, wie deine Zähne funktionieren, du hast viel Kraft und du hast dich gerade in einer Seeku verbissen, wow, erst mal gut gemacht, aber lass mich dir erklären, wie deine Zähnchen funktionieren, denn du hast viel Kraft und wenig Kontrolle. Du fliegst auseinander und wir zusammen, ups, wie diese alten Erklärfilme. Du hast Zähnchen, ganz viel in einer Reihe, sobald du eins verlierst, kommst du von hinten nach. Ich hab mehr als einen! Aber Achtung, du hast nur sieben pro Reihe, das heißt, verliere niemals sieben mal den gleichen Zahn. Also jetzt noch sechs. Ja. Oh, geil. Aber das ist schon gut. Und dann denkt man sich, was erwartet ihr, dass ich für ein Leben führe, dass ich jeden Zahn sieben mal raushau. Also es ist einfach wie absolute Overkill. Die meisten Haie sterben mit zwei Zähnen, die benutzt wurden von sie und man denkt sich so was genau erwartet ihr von mir stell dir vor haare würden so funktionieren wie haizähne das heißt du hast sieben shots in deinem leben pro haar pro jeden einzelnen haar pro jedes haar also eigentlich pro frisur also dass du hast wenn du sagst alles wächst sieben Einmal nach. Das wäre das Äquivalent zu Haizähnen. Ja, okay. Du hast sieben Shots, hast du. Oh, ich habe die nicht gefärbt, oh nein. Dann kommst du einmal ab, alles ausreißen, dann kommst du wieder nach. Ja. So eine Länge, die du willst. Du kannst, also es wächst nach, so Jesus-Style. Aber es wächst konstant nach oder kann man sagen, jetzt ist weg, jetzt kommt das neue? Nee, wie ein Zahn, wie ein Haizahn. Also wenn die Frisur abrasiert wurde, erst dann fängt es an zu wachsen. Genau, das wächst nicht ständig. Wie genau, wie ein Haizahn. Das ist gerade das Bit, in dem wir sie... Ich versuch's nur, die Eckpunkte abzuhagen. Okay, also wir sind in einem starren Gag-Raum. Wir sind in einem Multiversum, in dem alles so ist wie hier, nur die Haare wachsen nicht konstant, sondern erst wenn sie abgeschnitten wurden und wachsen nur sieben Mal nach. Und zwar wachsen sie immer einmal wie so die Jesusfrisur, bei meinen Männern zum Beispiel, so ein schulterlanges Haar. Und dann kannst du, es läuft passiert sofort, und dann kannst du daraus deine neue Frisur schneiden. Du könntest jetzt auch mit einem Satz Haaren mehrere Frisuren machen, Langhaarfrisur, kurz so wie so eine Puppe, wo wenn
Kinder so eine Puppe haben, kann man denen die
Haare schneiden, aber dann sagen die Eltern immer,
okay, du kannst ja in der Puppe die Haare schneiden, aber bitte denk dran,
dass du nie wieder
zurückgehen kannst.
Du kannst jetzt nur noch kürzer schneiden.
Wenn dir die Frisur nicht gefällt,
dann musst du all in gehen und noch kürzer schneiden.
Und dann haben wir irgendwann ein Problem.
Wie sieht die Welt aus ja wie ich glaube das könnte eine serie sein oder man fällt in so ein dimensionsportal und findet sich in einer welt wieder die exakt so ist wie die eigene nur das haare das haare ach so und dann so beim friseur ja ich hätte gerne einen kurzen schnitt und der friseur so sind sie sich wirklich sicher das ist der einzige und du so hä wie meinen sie Und er so, ne, ich hätte gerne einen Kurzhaarschnitt. Und der Friseur so, sind Sie sich wirklich sicher? Das ist der einzige Unterschied.
Und du so, hä, wie meinen Sie?
Und er so, naja, Ihnen ist schon klar,
dass Sie nur noch sechs Mal nachwachsen.
und du so wie wie wie wie noch mal ganz kurz noch mal kann man gehen kann man gehen na ja es ist doch so hier sind kaffee in der hand bitte noch mal es ist doch so wenn man die haare komplett
abschneidet dann wachsen sie nur sieben mal nach ich sehe gerade an ihrer kopfhaut sie haben schon
drei hinter sich sie haben nur noch vier ganze Haarlängen. Florian, wir sind nicht in unserem Universum gelandet. Was sagst du? Mit unserem Multiversum-Surfbrett. Was? Nein, ich bin gespannt, was hier noch anders ist. Nichts. Lebt Hitler noch? Nichts. Eine Anmerkung der Autoren, nichts. Nichts ist anders. Ah, okay, alles klar. Wir sind im Streik. Nichts ist anders. Es ist nur diese, diese High-Haar-Variante, die ist anders. Danke. Okay, ich sag Stefan. Stefan, ich glaube, das ist wirklich das einzige, was hier anders ist. Ah, okay, dann können wir ja auch hier bleiben. Dann müssen wir nicht unser Multidimensions-R- Rhönrad benutzen, um in eine andere Dimension zu kommen. Ja, Dimension zu kommen. Ich habe mir gerade vorgestellt, wie unser Rhönrad, wie wir uns beide reinstellen und sagen, Multiversum, aktivieren! Und wir sind so unangenehm nah aneinander. Und wir sagen in Folge 1, wollen wir nicht Rücken zu Bauch? Genau, aber ändern es nie. Oder wollen wir Bauch zu Bauch? Und man denkt, warum ändern es nicht? Und nach dreieinhalb Staffeln sagen sie, nun pass auf, können wir noch mal über die Röhnrad-Situation sprechen? Ja. Weil du hast ja Kopf oben, ich habe ja Kopf unten. Spannender Satz, können wir noch mal über die Röhnrad-Situation sprechen? Ich glaube, ich freue mich immer übersetzt, wenn ich die höre und denke, wurden die jemals schon mal so gesagt auf dem Planeten? Sehr gut, ja. Und ich glaube, der Satz, wir müssen noch mal dringend über die Rhönrad-Situation sprechen, ist noch nicht so häufig gefallen. Außer in einem Haushalt, wo Lisa anfängt, Rhönrad über ihre Englisch-Schulnote zu setzen. Okay. Und da kann ich mir vorstellen, dass der Vater sagt, Lisa, wir müssen noch mal über die Rhönrad-Situation sprechen. Und ohne dass es in die ronischen Kontexten gibt. Ja, Manfred und ich haben dir das Rhönrad gekauft, weil du gesagt hast, dass du trotzdem noch eine Hausaufgabe machst. Aber Rhönrad ist mein Leben. Ja, das hast du schon. Wieder ein Satz, wo ich glaube. Aber Rhönrad sind ganz geil eigentlich. Ja, Bullshit. Auch im Satz, der noch nie gefallen ist.
Ich hatte auch schon mal die Ehre, aber ich glaube, es gibt zwei. Es gibt die mit zwei Ringen, die stabil stehen, und dann gibt es die, die nur ein Ring sind, wo man dann sich selbst so aufbauen muss.
Ja, die mag ich.
Und die mit zwei, da war ich auch schon mal drin, und wenn man da so ein bisschen Unterarmkraft hat.
Ich habe die Fresse gelegt bestimmt.
Ja, es war sehr schmerzhaft.
Ja, heute, ich war noch ab einem kleinen Moment noch Genossen im Park, war im Park,
ist mein Franz, äh,
ist mein Wuppi und
Oh Gott sei Dank hast du dir das gerade
gestellt, holy shit ey.
Es hätte alles keinen Sinn mehr. Du, als wenn du hier anfängst, hier rumzulügen
oder Dinge zu verändern oder nicht genauso
zu erzählen, wie sie waren. Würde ich nicht machen.
Ne? Von mir keine Lüge. Gott sei Dank hast du dich da jetzt gebremst und gesagt, nee, diese paar Sekunden nehme ich mir. Wir haben nur eine Stunde Zeit, aber dann nehme ich mir kurz die Zeit, um zu sagen, nein, es war kein Sorry. Diese Anekdote hat Echtheitszertifikat. Sorry? Habe ich mich jetzt verrannt? Ah, okay, wenn das aber jetzt der Deal ist, dann müssen wir nochmal über ein paar Anekdoten sprechen. Also, ich saß da, ass mein Zimt-Wuppi. Und dann, da sind halt auch so Kinder unterwegs und da so gedönst. Und dann sehe ich so, wie so eine Familie ankommt, anscheinend zwei Familien, zwei Mütter mit ihren jeweiligen Töchtern, die so fahren, die Kinder fahren vorne Fahrrad, die Mütter da hinten nebeneinander. Und dann fahren die so und kommen näher, kommen näher und ich hatte gleich so Assoziationen im Kopf und dann, kurz bevor die auf meiner Höhe waren, fängt eines der Kinder an zu schlingern, schlingert, schlingert in das andere Kind rein und sie fallen beide komplett vor mir auf den Schotter, wirklich genau vor mir, bleiben sie liegen und natürlich denkt man sich erstmal, die Eltern sind da, ich muss jetzt nicht, was soll ich machen, da sind jetzt zwei Kinder umgefallen, Fahrrad, ist nicht meine Aufgabe.
War es denn so ein schlimmer Anblick oder war es ein okayer? Beide fangen sofort an zu weinen. Es war keine schlimme Verletzung, aber beide Mütter stiegen sofort ab, kümmern sich um die Mädchen und dann sind aber erst das Fahrrad der einen Mutter noch umgefallen, dann musste die das wieder aufstellen, dann ist das Fahrrad der anderen Mutter umgefallen, dann musste die das aufstellen. In der Zwischenzeit hatte eines der Mädchen das Fahrrad wieder aufgestellt, hat noch geweint, dann wollte die Mutter sich darum kümmern, das Kind lässt das Fahrrad los, das Fahrrad fällt um.
Das war wirklich ein Riesendrama und ich sß einfach so ganz unangenehm mittendrin, einfach mit jetzt, weil ich will ja auch nicht angewidert gehen, ich war gerade einfach Teil eines Dramas, eines Spektakels und ich wollte nicht Teil davon sein und war einfach nur beteiligt und es war richtig unangenehm, weil ich kann nicht eingreifen, ich kann nichts machen. Es klingt ein bisschen so, als wäre den Töchtern das Ungeschick schon in die Wiege gelegt. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Muss ich sagen, wenn den Eltern die ganze Zeit die Fahrräder umkippen. Noch cooler hätte ich es gefunden, wenn hinter den Eltern noch die Grosseltern, also zwei Omas gewesen wären. Genau, die dann den Eltern helfen. Und so geballte Female Energy-Generationen, so eine Kolonne. Die Lawine, ja, so eine Energielawine, die von einer Generation zur nächsten runtergeht. Meine Nachbarn haben Zwillinge und dann sind da die beiden Nachbarn mit Kinderwagen gefahren, weil eben noch mehr Kinder und davor gingen zwei Kinder, die so Puppen-Kinderwagen auch haben. Ah, geil. Und dann war wirklich so eine Kolonne wie eine Miniatur. Es gibt eine Miniatur, geht von weg. Ja, wie so die Pokémon-Entwicklungen, wenn die zusammen sind. Das war komplett absurd. Ich glaube, es ist auch unangenehm, wenn Turtok, Sherlock und Shiggy sich treffen in der Fussgängerzone und man so, grüsst man sich oder ist es so hi oder ist es so ein ... Ich war mal wie du. Weiß ich nicht. Ich war mal wie du. Ich war mal wie du. Eigentlich ist es wie, man trifft sein früheres Ich eigentlich ein bisschen. Ja, in gewisser Weise. Oder man trifft jemanden, der so war, wie du warst. Ja, genau. Aber er weiss nicht, wie es ist, du zu sein. Aber du weisst, es ist wie ... Also eigentlich sollte jeder Schillock mal einen Turtalk treffen, weil ich glaube, Turtalks können Schillocks wertvolle Tipps über ihr Leben geben. Wirklich. Ich glaube, Turtalks können eine Menge beibringenen und ich glaube schillocks sollten auch den schickis eine menge beibringen ich glaube schickis sollten sich ein bisschen zurücknehmen was würdest du sagen du gehst in park und du siehst auf der parkbank sitzend ein glumander und ein schillock händchen haltend ein glumander und schillock ja also die erste erste Generation Feuer und die zweite Generation Wasser sitzen auf einem Park und die halten die Hände. Was würdest du tun? Ich würde vorbeilaufen, in dem Szenario würde ich ein alter Mann mit so einer Schirmmütze und so einem Stock, um das zu sehen und zu sagen, un unnatürlich und weiterlaufen. Okay. Dann würde mir zu Hause meine Tochter sagen, es ist nicht, es ist völlig okay, also es ist völlig akzeptiert. Okay, du gehst weiter auf der nächsten Parkbank, siehst du ein Pikachu und ein Diktri, händchenhaltend. Bin ich nur noch dieser alte Mann? Ja. Du bist du. Du bist du. Erd-Pokémon und Strom-Pokémon. Richtig. Strom-Pokémon. Wie man richtig sagt. Wie man richtigerweise sagt. Würde ich sagen, die Welt geht vor die Hunde. Okay. Alles klar. Du gehst weiter. Die nächste Parkbank, ein Safcon und ein Omot.
Jesus Christ.
Händchen haltend.
Ein Safcon? Weißt das nochmal, dieser Kokon?
Sterfoss Medbo.
Der Kokon?
Ja.
Aber nicht der andere Kokon, es gibt zwei Kokons.
Nein, nein.
Es gibt zwei Kokon-Pokemon.
Ja.
Nicht so, ähPokémon. Ja. Nicht so Kokona.
Ja, ist egal. Du musst es nicht sagen.
Das wollte ich jetzt gar nicht.
Und was noch? Und Omot.
Das ist auch noch ein Motten-Pokémon.
Was aus Kokona wird.
Nein, eben nicht.
Das entwickelt sich einfach direkt. Eben nicht. Bibor wird aus
Kokona. Es gibt noch Omot separat, Omot hat nichts mit denen zu tun. Ich hätte einen Schlagernfall. Ich könnte mit dieser Information nicht umgehen und würde sagen, ich würde meine Tochter anrufen, ob die mich nicht abholen kann. Okay, die nächste Parkbank, du siehst ein Mirapla und die Arenaleiterin Misty. So, also jetzt reicht es vorbei. Tschüss, das war die Anekdote. Da fliegt sie davon. Ciao, komm gut, komm gut nach heim. Händchen halten. Nicht, dass du irgendwie jetzt zu schnell fährst oder einen Unfall hast oder so. Ciao Anekdote, komm gut nach Hause, tschüss. Moment mal, die Anekdote trägt gar keinen Sicherheitsgurt. Oh nein, oh nein. W. Wollen wir es ihr nicht sagen? Nee, ach alles gut, lass sie ziehen. Moment mal, die Anekdote, da ist aber der Scheinwerfer aus, der liegt, der Scheinwerfer ist kaputt. Umdrehen. Na nee, hol sie nicht zurück. Die Anekdote fährt falsch rum in eine Einbahnstrasse. Lass sie ziehen. Die Anekdote fährt falsch rum in eine Einbahnstrasse rein. Wir wussten, dass sie ganz groben Unfug macht. Wir wussten, dass diese Anekdote rückwärts in eine Einbahnstrasse reinfährt. Wir wissen auch, dass sie noch einen Fußgänger mitzieht. Ja, okay. Das war uns allen klar. Ich bin unangenehm. Ist mir aufgefallen. Also ich bin sehr, sehr, sehr uncool. In einer Sache. Okay, sag erst mal du. Das ist mir so peinlich.
Aber es ist mir eingefallen, dass man es sich immer macht. cool. In einer Sache. Okay, sag erst mal du.
Das ist mir so peinlich.
Aber es ist mir eingefallen, dass ich es immer mache.
Ich immer, wenn ich mich vorstelle, wenn ich mich frage, wie heisst du, und ich sage Stefan,
ich sage meinen Namen, gebe ich die Hand.
Und erst mal wirkt es nicht so
schlimm, aber selbst im Club
irgendwie, wenn man jemanden anspricht oder
kennenlernt oder sowas, man spricht schon vielleicht eine halbe Stunde oder länger, man tanzt schon. Und dann fragt man sich, wie heisst du, sag ich, Stefan, gebe ich trotzdem die Hand. Okay. Ich strecke so wie so ein Bürgermeister im Wahlkampf. Aber du hast wirklich diesen strammen, auch ausgestreckten Arm, hast du ihn auch angewinkelt? Nee, so wirklich wie der Bürgermeister im Wahlkampf, sage ich. Freut mich Stefan. Und ich finde das so peinlich. In dem Moment finde ich es auch peinlich. Aber es ist ein Reflex von dir. Gott, es ist ein Reflex. Das gehört bei dir zusammen. Vorstellen und Handberührung. Ja, es ist irgendwie konnektiert mit meinem Kopf und ich finde es so peinlich. Ich finde es nicht peinlich im Club. Wie heisst du überhaupt? Stefan. Ich höre alles auf, ich höre auf zu trinken, ich höre auf zu tanzen, ich gehe in den Bürgermeister und sag, oh, freut mich sehr, deine Bekanntschaft zu machen, mein Name ist Stefan, Sohn des Wolfgang. Hallo. Aber es ist schon gut, weil ich glaube, es ist egal, in welcher Situation schweren Handschlag abzulehnen. Weil ich glaube, Handschlag ist einfach direkt Reaktion drin. Du bist sofort drin. Weil ich sehe immer in dem Gesicht des Gegenübers so ein... Also niemand schlägt den aus, niemand schlägt den Handschlag aus, aber es ist unangenehm. Und dann manchmal dieses Mundwinkel, die ich nach unten ziehe, dieses, oh, freu mich, Stefan. Ja, ich tue mich auch manchmal schwer... Ich tue mit Sprechen. Mit der richtigen Grammatik der deutschen Sprache. Nee, du hast richtig. Ich tue mich schwer. Ja, ich habe es mir mittlerweile so gemerkt, sag so wie du denkst, dass es falsch ist. So habe ich es mir gemerkt. Das stört mich aber jetzt. Ich tue mich immer schwer mit der Begrüssung von Leuten, die man schon auf eine Art kennt, aber noch nie wirklich direkt gesehen hat.
Ein Beispiel, zum Beispiel, bei Rocket Beans
TV gibt es ja immer Sendungen und da gibt es die Regie.
Die Regie, die
interagiert mit einem in der Sendung, die sagt,
ah, jetzt fünf Minuten, blablabla und so.
Und man hat mit denen, man kennt die seit Jahren.
Jetzt fünf Minuten lustiger sein.
Aber
man hat, man sieht die
nicht ständig so. Man geht an der Regie
vorbei und da war es auch mal so, dass ich die mal so privat
hatte, jemand Geburtstag aus der Firma
Aber Aber man hat, man sieht die nicht ständig so, man geht an der Regie vorbei und da war es auch mal so, dass ich die mal so privat hatte, jemand Geburtstag aus der Firma und da habe ich jemanden aus der Regie, mit dem ich seit vier Jahren zusammenarbeite, getroffen und es war so, ah, und geht zur Umarmung und merkt in der Umarmung, das ist nicht die Ebene. das ist nicht die Ebene, wo ich mir dachte, eigentlich, also ich habe so in meinem Kopf die Fakten, man kennt sich lange, man arbeitet zusammen, man hat schon Witze gemacht oder so, aber halt immer über diese digitale Ebene, halt über Mikrofone und In-Ears und sowas nie wirklich sich gesehen und in dem Moment war es für beide so, das war schon ein Moment, wo ich gedacht habe, ich gehe. Als jemand, der dich gut kennt, kann ich dir sagen, man freut sich, wenn man von dir eine Umarmung bekommt.
Och, das freut mich. Ich umarme auch gerne.
Ah, hast du das Kompliment wahrgenommen? Ich war gar nicht so gemeint. Man freut sich, dass man von dir irgendwas, also irgendeine Form von Zuneigung oder so bekommt. Zu Ufo ist pink gewor... Okay, never mind. Spinnig? Ich weiss es nicht. Ich weiss nicht genau, nach welchen Parametern man die Farbe endet. Aber das ist der Moment, wo ich den Club verlassen würde. Ich meine, es gibt ja... Von mir? Einen Anschlag zu bekommen? Weiss ich nicht. Ich würde mich dann echt nicht mehr wohlfühlen. Ich glaube, ich würde mich nicht mehr wohlfühlen. Auch da, das war ein komischer Abend und ich hatte schon den Reflex, ich verlasse den Club und die Bitches und so weiter. Du hast ja in solchen Songs oft, ich komme in den Club und so, aber Florentin und Stefan kommen in den Club, schmeissen die Becher um und haben den Regenschirm dabei, wo mit dem Regenschirm hin, ist er noch feucht, ich klatsche auf dem dancefloor mit dem pulli ist so warm ich ziehe ihn lieber aus und nein mein ganzes t-shirt wird mitgezogen was
machen wir denn hier wir sind körperkläuse Brille ist beschlagen wohin mit dem Rucksack
Garderobe fünf Euro Pfand wo ist mein Geldbeutel? Ich habe kein Bargeld, die Nase ist ganz rot, draußen ist es kalt, die Nase ist ganz rot. Und die Bitches sagen wow und wir sagen ho, wir wollen eigentlich nach Hause, die Bitches auf dem Dancefloor. Die wollen auf dem Dancefloor. Die wollen immer auf dem Dancefloor. Währenddessen wir nach Hause wollen, obschon die, warum nicht mal so eine Sprache in den modernen Hip-Hop reinbringen. Sorry, dass wir nicht gereimt haben, das ist der nächste Schritt. Er ist der nächste Schritt. Am Ende des Raps, ja sorry, dass wir nicht gereimt haben, aber uns sind leider relativ schnell die Reims ausgegangen und wir hatten auch nicht so viel Zeit aufzunehmen. Sorry. war ein improvisiertes bit in dem sinne sind uns nicht sofort reime eingefallen grosses sorry an der stelle dafür wir werden da irgendwann aber drin besser finde ich aber gar nicht mal so schlecht so dieses klassische wir kommen in den club pump it up aber halt wirklich nur unangenehm man will eigentlich wieder direkt ist gar nicht so schlecht und man verlässt den Club. Wir verlassen den Club und die Leute sagen, gar nichts, sie wussten nicht, dass ich da bin, sie wussten nicht, ich habe mich nicht verabschiedet. Ja, den polnischen machen oder wie die Schweizer sagen, den französischen machen. Okay, und die Franzosen sagen, den Französischen machen.
Okay, und die Franzosen sagen, den Deutschen machen.
Das glaube ich nicht, weil die Deutschen sind nicht dafür bekannt, wieder einfach zu gehen. Das stimmt, ja. Die Engländer sagen, den Iren machen. Daran müssen wir arbeiten. Ich finde es interessant, alle nehmen das Nachbarland einfach, was sie nicht mögen, wo es Verfeindungen gibt. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Sollte man das noch sagen? Lieber nicht. Ich weiss es auch nicht genau, was das für eine Idee ist, aber ... Nein, ich weiss nicht, mir tut es leid, wenn ich da Leute schon mal irgendwie irritiert habe mit diesem Handschlag.
Ich weiss, es ist so uncool. Ich will an der Arbeit viel cooler werden.
Manche strahlen so eine natürliche Coolness aus. Ja, die Begrüßung ist es schwer. Auch Check habe ich nie wirklich eine Schulter. Wann kommt der linke Arm noch dazu und was ist dann los? Brauchst nicht checken. Man kommt gut durchs Leben ohne Checks. Ja, ich weiß schon., aber ich weiss nicht, wie man reingehen soll, mit welcher Energie.
Das ist einfach wirklich schwer.
Eine schwere Choreografie unserer Zeit.
Ist das Leben nicht die härteste Choreografie?
Ja, oder halt Cats.
Das ist, glaube ich, auch sehr schwer.
Dieser geschmeidige Gang, wie so eine Katze, dass die Schultern so ... Das ist, glaube ich, sehr schwer.
Das ist, glaube ich, echt nicht so leicht zu tanzen. Ich habe Respekt vor Tänzern. Du verachtest Tänzer. Ich habe grossen Respekt vor Tänzer. Ich liebe Tänzer. Und gerade so jetzt in der TikTok-Epoche, in der wir uns wählen. Ich wünschte, ich könnte gut tanzen.
Und so, also tanzen ist, glaube ich, die Kunstform unserer Zeit.
Sie ist multilingual, sie ist international, sie ist gut, sehr gut kommerzialisierbar, sie ist ein ein gemeinschaftserlebnis man tanzt zusammen dauert nicht so lange weil exakt so ein ganzes ballett puh aber so ein tik tok so so zack wunderbar reicht mir auch wunderbar was für ein teufel ist das für ein geräusch naja geht schon schon weggehen irgendwann wieder. Du, ich bin ein bisschen paranoid, weil ich habe immer noch im Hinterkopf, dass wir heute nicht aufnehmen sollten, dass irgendeine höhere Macht versucht, die Aufnahme zu verhindern, dass es irgendein Final Destination Ding ist, das wir heute nicht aufnehmen dürfen, sonst hört die Person dann den neuen Podcast und fährt mit dem Fahrrad vor das Auto oder sowas in der Richtung. Oder schlimmer noch, ist auf einem langen Ausflug mit Leuten, die man nicht so gut kennt, hat eigentlich die Podcast-Folge gehört und dann passiert irgendwas auf diesem Roadtrip, wo man eigentlich sagt, wir haben eigentlich genug Stoff für die Fahrt. Zum Beispiel, nee, lass es mich anders sagen, könntest du dir jemals vorstellen, Elektroauto zu fahren? Definitiv. So, weil ich nämlich nicht. Warum nicht? Weil ich hätte Angst, ich hätte Angst, dass wenn man eine lange Reise plant und man sagt so, wir fahren jetzt irgendwie nach Paris oder so, man fährt jetzt wirklich weit weg Roadtrips so den ganzen Tag. Wow, das ist die weiteste Stadt, die da eingefallen ist, Paris, zwei Stunden von hier, urgemäß. Knackige zwei Stunden. Okay, aber dann steht nämlich, so angenommen wir beide, wir fahren nach Paris, so die Stimmung angespannt. Okay, ja, nee, ich wäre aufgeregt. Und dann siehst sag Stefan, im Vergleich zum Elektromotor ist das kaum was, und du sagst, kannst du das bitte machen für mich? Wir haben ein ganz, ganz spannendes Problem jetzt. Weil entweder wir fahren mit Musik ans Ziel, also kommen nicht ans Ziel, müssen dann an Raststätte, müssen dann nicht reden, aber müssen mehr Zeit miteinander verbringen. Genau. Und Raststätte auch nur überbrücken, weil so ein Autoladen dauert ja. Du hast Menschen so sehr, ich rede ja auch einfach sehr gerne mit Menschen, also mit Menschen, die ich mag, rede ich wahnsinnig gern. Der Fakt, dass du dann Angst hast, dass irgendwie keine Musik, finde ich so interessant. Aber da sind wir auch anders, glaube ich, auch muss man noch akzeptieren, aber ich finde, das ist wahnsinnig schlimm. Ich finde ganz im Gegenteil viel schlimmer, weil es wirklich neulich passiert ist. Ich habe mit einer Freundin ein Auto abgeholt, sie hat ein neues Auto. Wir mussten mit einem Auto hingefahren, sie ist mit ihrem zurück und ich mit dem neuen zurück. und es ist so ein älteres auto und es hat kein radio und das habe ich und es gab noch kein
kabel zum connecten des handys Und dann habe ich so angeboten, das neue Auto zu fahren und so. Okay, easy, mache ich. Und in dem Moment, wo ich merke, ich habe gar kein Radio oder keine Musik, habe ich wirklich so einen Anflug von Panik bekommen. Ah, ich bin jetzt anderthalb Stunden mit meinen Gedanken alleine.
In Geiselhaft mit sich selbst. Wirklich. Und das fand ich interessant. Das krieg ich nicht hin. Das fand ich, hat dann gut geklappt, auch weil ich dann doch irgendwie auf dem Radio gekommen bin. Du hattest noch ein Quartett in der Rucksacktasche zum Glück. Nochmal irgendwie die schnellsten Jets der Welt. Boah, aber das war so spannende fünf Minuten, wo ich dachte, es gibt kein Radio, gab es dann, aber diese Minuten, wo man dachte, Wahnsinn, dass man das nicht mehr hinkriegt und wann ist man mal mit seinen Gedanken, also ein kompletter Stille alleine, ist man selten, also auch beim Sport hat man immer was im Ohr oder beim Kochen oder so, eigentlich immer, wenn es den Anflug von Stille gibt, hat man irgendwie eine Beschallung. Ja, dieser Podcast zum Beispiel, gemacht um euch vom Denken abzuhalten. Oder euren Doofen, aber Erkenntnis ist nicht die brillanteste Erkenntnis, aber hat mir sehr viel geholfen in letzter Zeit. Nicht jeder Gedanke, den er hat, diese berühmten Gedanken, mit denen ihr nicht alleine sein wollt, sind richtig. Das mag jetzt sehr einfach klingen, viele hatten diese Erkenntnis schon, ich habe 29 Jahre meines Lebens gebraucht, um herauszufinden, nein, nicht jeder Gedanke in deinem Kopf entspricht der Wahrheit. Sie sind falsch, sie sollen das Maul halten, sie flieger nur Scheiss. Ja, es ist interessant, weil die Gedanken kommen ja von dir. Und man denkt ja, dann sind die auch, dann muss da was dran sein. Dann sind die ja ich. Aber du bist ja ein Trottel. Du denkst ja völligen Quatsch. Man denkt manchmal wahnsinnig Unsinn und das ist nicht gut und das macht einen vielleicht auch unglücklich. Man muss die dann hören und ernst nehmen und man kann mit denen in den Dialog treten. Seid das nicht, redet nicht ständig mit euren Gedanken, aber man kann dann sagen so, ah, ah, spannend, das kommt daher und vielleicht kriegt man Rückschlüsse auf sein altes Leben. Du hast dann wie so eine Gruppe Freunde im Kopf, wo Rudi sagt, ah, mach mal das und ah, die erwarten bestimmt, dass du das machst und du sagst, ja Rudi, das ist jetzt deine Meinung. Eben, nicht Freunde, entfernte Bekannte. Ja, okay, entfernte Bekannte, so Onkel. Jeder hat den rassistischen Onkel in seinem Kopf, irgendwo ist die Frage, nehmt ihr den für wahre Münze? Nimm dir mal das Bier weg und setz dich mal hin. Man kann den einsperren kurz, man kann sagen, so Onkel Richard, es ist mal kurz raus. Und das ist okay. Also nicht alle Gedanken in deinem Kopf sind wahr. Aber gibt es überhaupt dann noch Stefan-Gedanken oder sind alle Gedanken im Kopf? Dann wird nämlich spannend, wer ist Stefan? Wer ist eigentlich Stefan? Wer ist denn eigentlich Stefan? Und ist er überhaupt, und was ist er davon? Also was muss ich muten? Oder ist nicht genau dieser handelnde Muter, der manche aufzieht? Der Gesprächspartner. Der am Mischpuls ist, der manche Stimmen lauter zieht und manche kleiner zieht. Die Regie quasi. Die Regie, bin ich nicht die Regie, Stefan nicht die Regie. Okay. Was der will, weiß ich auch nicht. Wo der hingeht, weiß ich auch nicht. Okay. Ob der die richtigen Entscheidungen und die richtigen Kanäle runterzieht, das weiß ich auch nicht. Das ist abzuwarten. Ich finde nur interessant, weil es mir geholfen hat. Wollte ich euch da draußen auch was mit an die Hand geben?
Absolut, ich distanziere mich auch immer weiter von meinen Gedanken. Ich sage, ich habe damit nichts zu tun, ich bin nicht so dumm, weil manchmal bin ich auch echt dumm und schäme mich, aber denke mir so, nee, nee, das ist schon okay. Zum Beispiel, ich habe grosse Angst davor, mich auszusperren. Das ist eine grosse, grosse Angst von mir. Und bei mir ist oft so das Problem, ich bin gerade am Gehen und denke dann noch so, ah, oh, habe ich mein Ladekabel dabei und gucke dann nochmal so in die Wohnung raus, habe aber irgendwie schon Müll rausgetragen und manchmal habe ich meinen Rucksack dann schon draußen oder drin, ich bin draußen und weiß nicht genau, wann geht die Tür zu und ich versuche mal ganz penibel aufzupassen, wann genau die Tür zu geht, wo jetzt gerade der Schlüssel ist, damit ich da ja keinen Fehler mache, weil ich habe da keinen Bock drauf, mich auszuschliessen.
Und heute war es so, ich war schon mal draussen im Treppenhaus, hab meinen Rucksack mit dem Schlüssel abgelegt, bin dann nochmal rein in die Wohnung, hab die Tür zugemacht und dachte mir, scheiße, ich hab mich eingesperrt, weil der Schlüssel war draußen und ich war drin und ich dachte mir, fuck, dachte mir, ah nee, du kannst ja von innen einfach die Tür aufmachen, das ist überhaupt kein Problem, aber ich hatte für so einen Moment diesen, oh fuck, jetzt hänge ich hier und in meinem Kopf war Feuerwehreinsatz, Leiter ans Fenster, Schlüsseldienst, wie komme ich raus, Bettlaken, Seil aus dem Fenster raus und dann plötzlich so ein, ach nee, alles, alles weg, alles auf Wiedervorlage, alle packen ihre Pläne wieder ein und so, okay, der Plan ist da. Wie in New York. Ich habe dir gesagt, kannst du den Schlüssel rauslegen, da muss ich ihn nicht wecken, ich komme wahrscheinlich später, dann kann ich einfach, draussen hat mir so eine Schlüsselbox, dann konnte man das da verstauen, ich konnte einfach die aufmachen und komm rein, ohne dass du, dass ich nachts den schlaftrunkenen Florentin noch wecken muss, der dann mit seiner Laterne und der Schlafmütze die Treppe runterkommt. Bei der Stefan ein aktives Nachtleben hat. Wer ist da? Wer stört? Wer klingelt zu so später Stund?
Wer stört? Nein, nein, nein. Ja, weil du ein aktives Nachtleben hast und ich bin der Nerd, der um zehn im Bett liegt. Aktives Sexleben führt. Da komme ich natürlich nachts einfach nach Hause mit zerrüttelten Haaren und Schweissshirt. Aber da habe ich mich auch verheddert im Kopf. Da habe ich mich verheddert, weil ich dachte... Florentin schreibt, ich glaube nicht, dass es geht. Dass ich den Schlüssel, also da gibt es so eine Zahlenschlossbox vor der Tür und ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass ich... Stell dich vor, Tür, die man abschliessen kann und draußen ist eine Box. Florentin hat mir geschrieben, ja ich glaube nicht, dass ich den Schlüssel rauslegen kann, ohne dass ich mich aussperre. Ja, weil ich dachte, wenn ich draußen bin und die Tür absperre, dann komme ich ja selber nicht mehr rein. Was ich nicht wusste, ist, dass man ohne Schlüssel die Tür absperren kann, was in meiner Welt nicht selbstverständlich ist. Wie? Dass man ohne Schlüssel die Tür absperren kann. Muss man ja nicht, kann ja auch offen sein. Doch, die hat ja so einen Hebel, dass man auch einfach reinkommt, die hat ja so einen Drehknauf. Jede Tür, die man, ach so, du hast Angst. Nicht jede Tür kann man ohne Schlüssel absperren. Aber du kannst doch die Tür auflassen, gehst raus, machst sie da rein, gehst wieder rein. Aber dann ist sie ja in meinen Augen nicht zugesperrt, wenn man den Schlüssel zum Absperren braucht. Aber, um es aufzulösen, man konnte die Türen auch mit Drehriegeln verschließen. Warum muss sie abgesperrt sein, die Tür für dich? Weil sie sonst nicht abgesperrt ist. Ist doch scheißegal. Dann brauchst du ja auch keinen Schlüssel, wenn sie nicht abgesperrt ist. Ja, zum Beispiel. Da brauche ich dir auch den Schlüssel nicht rauslegen, wenn die Tür nicht abgesperrt ist. Dann kann ich die Schlüssel auch behalten. Ja, völlig richtig. Ja, aber dann ist die Tür nicht abgesperrt und ich schlafe und jeder kommt rein. Was soll denn jeder bei dir? Ja, Stefan, aber wenn du jetzt so anfängst, dann brauchen wir keine Schlüssel mehr. Also das ist ein netter Gedanke, aber das ist einfach ... Etwa dann hatte ich einen Knoten im Kopf, bin ich ehrlich. Nee, es stimmt schon, ich wusste nicht, dass man die Türen von innen abschließen kann, aber man sollte die Türen abschließen. Es gab ja mal diesen FBI-Typen, die Serie Mindhunter, ich weiß nicht, ob die jetzt so im popularen Bewusstsein istsein ist, aber da geht es sozusagen um den ersten Polizisten, FBI-Agenten, der sagt, lass uns mal mit Tätern reden, lass uns mal gucken, wie die denken. Das moderne Profiling aufgemacht. Genau, also dann können wir vielleicht besser Verbrechen präventiv bekämpfen, wenn wir verstehen, wie Serienmörder, die wir gefasst haben, funktionieren. Dann hat er angefangen, mit Leuten zu reden und dann gab es einen berühmten Massenmörder und dann haben die den interviewt und dann haben die überlegt, ja was ist das psychologisch, die Opfer, wie sehen die aus, haben die irgendwelche Eigenschaften, die ähnlich sind, was kann man da verbinden, sind es Figuren aus seiner Vergangenheit, irgendwie die Mutter, klassisch Vater, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung und dann haben die mit dem geredet, dann haben die den nicht geknackt gekriegt. Dann wollte er nicht sagen, was los ist. Da muss irgendein Geheimnis dahinter sein. Irgendwas ist da, irgendeine Verbindung, die wir nicht sehen, irgendein Muster, das wir nicht sehen. Und dann irgendwann haben sie dann, meinte der so, ja, ich bin ziemlich, der hat dann trainiert im Gefängnis und meinte dann so, ja, das sieht ziemlich gut aus, so seine Muskeln. Und er dachte so, okay, jetzt haben wir ihn, er ist eitel, so kriegen wir ihn, so kommen wir an ihn ran. Und dann haben die ihn dazu bestärkt und er sagt, ja toll, können wir nicht ein Foto machen und so und wie toll sie aussehen. Und dadurch haben sie ihn dann langsam weich gekriegt und irgendwann hat er dann gesagt, was seine Opfer sind und dachten, okay, jetzt haben wir den Fall. Und er meinte, ich habe einfach geguckt, bei welchen Türen es nicht abgesperrt ist, bin reingegangen, habe alle umgebracht. Und deswegen, glaube ich, ist es gar nicht so schlecht, seine Tür abzuschliessen, weil sonst ist man in einer gewissen Täter-Opfer-Klasse mit drin. Ich habe doch recht, also bei meiner Tür, jede Tür ist abgesperrt, wenn man die immer zumacht. Nee, die nicht, die hatte ja diesen Drehknauf. Ja, aber trotzdem, jede andere, doch, ging die ja auch, ging ja dann auch, wie gesagt. Ja, ging ja dann auch, weil sie einen Riegel hatte, den man händisch ohne Schlüssel drehen konnte, was ich nicht wusste. Meine ich aber, aber es ist wie dann im Kern, wie genau das, dieses Mechanik ist, egal, es ist wie ja jede fucking Tür in Deutschland, wenn man es zumacht, ist so. Stefan, du weißt, du weißt, dass Schloss- und Schlüsselsysteme immer bei mir sind mir sind ja das war ein thema bei dir und dass du da jetzt so drauf rummacht ja ich möchte nur nicht als der trottel über diese diskussion rausgehen das ist ein thema bei mir mit abschliessen und schlüssel und ich habe dass du heulst und ich nicht mehr in die die die ja das weiß ich ja aber trotzdem finde ich es ein bisschen hart von dir ist wirklich so in wirklich so in meinem Leben, mir ist es wichtiger, Recht zu haben, als gemocht zu werden, manchmal, manchmal. Okay, aber warum willst du dann Recht haben? Ich dachte, normalerweise will man Recht haben, damit man gemocht wird, damit alle sagen, wow, wie gut er sich auskennt. Richtig, aber ich habe so ein Gerechtigkeitsding und will dann unbedingt Recht haben und natürlich, ich will lieber schlau gefunden werden. Ich tue jetzt auch so, als wäre dieses Konzept mir völlig fremd und wir uns nicht und schon seit neun Jahren kennen würden. Nee, und vor allem, klar, will man gemocht werden oder will man als sehr, sehr clever und rechtheibischer Wichser wahrgenommen werden? Das liebe ich. Ja, das ist ja ganz einfach. Gedanken können auch falsch sein. Die Gedanken sind falsch, sie hassen nur Scheisse, sie wiegen vorbei, macht sie lieber leise. Sie sind nicht immer richtig, sie sind manchmal sogar nichtig, rassistisch und dumm, die Gedanken haut sie um. Ah, toll! Haben Sie jetzt, Entschuldigung, haben Sie jetzt nur für das Kölner Publikum die letzte Zeit noch mal so ein bisschen mit Köln gesungen, oder ist es dann auch, oder ist es in der ursprünglichen Liedversion auch so angelegt? Nee. Das heißt, Sie haben jetzt erstmal... Warum labern Sie mit dem Applaus hinweg? Entschuldigung, ich wollte... Das muss man ja als erfahrener Liedkünstler. Na, hause um na. Sehr schön. Guck mal, das ist doch gut. Ich glaube, wir schaffen es heute, Botschaften in Liedern zu verpacken. Wir haben angefangen mit Sand wird verbrannt, Sand wird verbrannt und enden mit einer wirklich sinnvollen psychologischen Lektion. Die Gedanken sind scheisse. Die Gedanken sind auch Quatsch manchmal, Rauschen vorbei.
Also vielleicht kann man ja auch einfach die Kunst der Musik nutzen, um Dinge zu erklären. Genau. Konzepte. Ja. Nochmal Vulkan. Undeliverance. Ja, was ist noch mal Was heißt das? Was ist noch mal eine Buch? Was will er uns damit sagen? Wie funktioniert das? Satz, aber gut, okay. Mathematik gibt es tatsächlich schon auf YouTube sehr viele Erklärvideos, die gerappt werden. Da bin ich ein großer Fan davon. Das will ich eigentlich zu jedem Thema. Zweiter Weltkrieg, komplett gerappt, nochmal mit wirklich guten Songs. Welches Jahr, wann war nochmal Stalingrad genau? Da einfach mal so ein Lied mit einem guten Reim. Und wie immer hinterlassen wir euch mit Stalingrad. Genau, ein Ereignis. Damit lassen wir euch jetzt wieder alleine und euren Gedanken. Ja, jetzt seid ihr wieder alleine mit euren Gedanken, aber ihr hofft, aber wir hoffen, dass ihr jetzt ein bisschen besser damit umgehen könnt, denn wir haben... Du redest gerade, als ob du die Sprache nicht sprichst. Also ob du eigentlich eine andere Sprache sprichst. Was ich noch sagen will. Leute. Okay. Akusten. Ich wünsche euch eine ganz schöne Zeit, Mr. Wobalova.
Wir sassen übrigens die ganze Zeit nur mit Handpuppen da. Wir haben die ganze Zeit mit Handpuppen ins Mikrofon gesprochen.
Wir wünschen euch eine ganz schöne Woche, haut rein und jetzt gehen wir steil sozusagen hoch in Luft in die Haus.
Tschüss und tschüss und blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla